The NBA has now announced the suspension of their season.
I'm just gonna read you their press release.
The NBA announced that a player on the Utah Jazz has preliminarily tested positive for COVID-19.
The test result was reported shortly...
...prior to the tip-off of tonight's game between the Jazz and the Oklahoma City Thunder...
...at Chesapeake Energy Arena in Oklahoma.
At that time, tonight's game was cancelled.
The affected player was not in the arena.
The NBA is suspending gameplay...
...following the conclusion of tonight's schedule of games until further notice.
The NBA will use this hiatus to determine next steps...
...for moving forward in regard to the coronavirus pandemic.
So again, moments ago, we had heard that game had been delayed and then called off.
We now know why it was.
Again, a Utah Jazz player has preliminarily tested positive.
That game is off tonight; the NBA season has been suspended.